let's talk about weed because I think
after last week everybody could use a
little weed in the country if there was
ever a time that America needed to take
one sort of massive bong and I think I
think this is it so a senior lecturer at
Harvard University jeffrey miron has
added up some numbers related to weed
and basically if we legalize we're going
to show you the graphic right now if we
legalized it would save us about 20
billion dollars a year that's be four
billion it would be about 8.7 billion
saved in law enforcement 8.7 generated
from taxes and then if you adjust for
inflation and i don't think that's 20
million bucks billion 20 billion did I
just say million because that's how
crazy it sounds it's crazy and value
that's not even including the revenue
from tasty cakes yeah exactly the people
at hostos that would solve that whole
Twinkie thing yeah i mean really netflix
would prosper i think people would be
nicer I think all wars would be cupcake
everybody calm down a little bit yeah
they would be fought over cupcakes or no
no they just eat cupcake it was your
Seneca everyone cares yeah is there any
reason that weed is not legalized I mean
we see these numbers all time I didn't
know about the 20 billion number but we
see this stuff all the time and it just
seems like why are why are we not doing
is or I guess we sort of slowly all
right down there I mean for medical use
in quotes yeah what's the revenue on
that though has been significant enough
to help prove that point I don't know
these things yeah yeah I mean I think
they in Washington they don't know how
much to tax right right you're still
figuring it all out and yet I see it as
I mean a cash crop no pun intended but I
do think that we're gonna have to
legalize it soon because the tobacco
crops are gonna need a new crime are
gonna need a new crop the earth people
are getting wiser right not because
we're gonna make it illegal but because
people are back slow
weaning themselves off actually because
they realize right and they're smoking
the electronic cigarettes now yeah I've
heard an ad for today thought you
weren't allowed to advertise for
cigarettes but I heard an ad for an
electronic cigarette you actually can't
advertise on television for regular
cigarettes but they're now letting you
know you can okay and but they're
letting them advertise for these
electronic cigarettes which supposedly
have like eight times the carthage in
carson really it's really well no smoke
though so that's but no smoke exactly oh
that you can also advertise for the
nicorette gum yeah the little band
that's practicing on your dashboard all
right what's that like either for nikah
red or chantix or some canned Ock's
there's something about that this seems
to me like this is definitely going in
the right direction though because it's
sort of like it seems like marriage
equality to me where the numbers just
keep ticking in the right way so is this
this is just a matter of time at this
point do you think I think so I mean I
think in the last episode of weeds they
it was flash forward into the future and
we saw that starbucks had bought out
Nancy bout wins whole business and hey
you never know I read something about
how they were getting vending machines
ready for to sell weed to sell weed I
always think it's weird that like we
never see bad examples where ever we has
been legalized and you can obviously
look at Amsterdam as as the number one
thing I mean the drug rates don't go up
the city then taxes it and they have
beautiful streets and cabs and nice
parks and everyone seems happier so
where what is the fear with weed what do
you think the fear really comes down to
Nancy Reagan yeah and just say no just
say no yeah um I don't know i mean it is
an evolution i suppose like marriage
equality in that when people are frantic
about the economy and most people not
most people i shouldn't say that people
who are not educated about what they're
arguing about when they start seeing
numbers that look good things make sense
to them and then they're willing to
adjust a little bit more so i think when
people see a number like 20 billion and
then you throw in some unemployment
numbers and this is shitty and that's
better people look for the better things
so
oh it kind of pushes it so you think
it's good that we're in the middle of a
recession or we're kind of getting out
or it's kind of getting worse depending
on who list do but that you throw out a
bit number like 20 billion and then
people will be like oh what show us
things that we went on the fence about
because I think some people don't give a
[ __ ] about weed and some people are very
and other people are there's also him
they can write that can do loathing and
right it's an away from values yeah
nothing to do with THC I actually think
part of the reason that people are
against weed whoever is left that it's
against is that they you know we'd
actually makes you think a little bit
you know any mean it makes you think and
the one thing the government can't have
citizens doing is thinking they can't
have us walking around thinking right
cuz what would have you were just
thinking of it they'd all be comedians
everywhere we are thinking but we'd also
be sleeping we do think sleeping well
yeah and you wouldn't have things I mean
no one no one gets stone and it's like
let's go for a joyride everyone's like
let's just sit here and watch TV for a
little bit so that would not be good for
the economy well no be great for the
economy because it be it would take away
from drunk driving perhaps people are
just gonna call pizza dominos right we
should have got stoned before this egg
and then really indomina and really
thought this thing out bonobos calm is
the official outfitter of the Ruben
report use code trr 20 for twenty
percent off your first purchase